got a session last night's strategy
session at the office till late last
night five hour meeting we had last
night Tom probably the best one we've
ever had second no joke we just unveiled
the vitamin's vision what we want to do
in 23 where we're going to be going in
the future different projects we have
and all the different leaders work in
different departments shared their
insight and what they're going to be
doing but here's what I will tell you
um 2023
it will be we gave it a name uh where
we're sitting down on time of what the
your name is going to be for the year
we're calling it The your building
character okay and to me what I mean by
Bureau building character if you say
you're going to do something do it okay
you're not going to get 100 score on
this you're just not because 100 means
no matter what numbers you put you're
going to hit 100 of your goals if you
hit 100 of your goals your goals were
too small if you're 20 of your goals
your goals were either out of whack and
you were not really sitting down
thinking about the goals you're just
kind of treating like homework but you
ought to hit about 80 your goals when
you're writing them down because some of
them should be a stretcher it's like how
the hell am I going to hit this number
what makes you fight for it but the only
reason why you will hit your goals for
2023 is because you're more concerned
about who you're becoming as a human
being than the actual goal character
building is about saying I'm gonna do x
y z working your tail off for hitting
that goal
Antonio Brown is sitting right here and
I'm trying to find this video I got to
somewhere around here uh Antonio Brown's
sitting right here we're going back and
forth during that podcast where we're
talking to him and in one of the
sessions he says you ain't you you don't
know where I'm from I'm from Liberty
City I'm from Liberty City I'm from La
he kept saying that again I'm like dude
I'm from L.A yeah but you grew up in the
nice parts of it I'm like dude you know
Liberty City people get shot I'm like
dude in Iran we get bombed yeah yeah but
you don't understand this this I'm like
dude this is just gonna go places so I
said you know what fine no problem
Antonio Brown you know what I'm gonna do
Rob I'm gonna text this to you to show
this video I said I'm gonna go you just
declined it I'm gonna go to
Liberty City yeah and you know what I'm
going to do I'm going to go be a cash
and not a cashier a bagger at
Winn-Dixie's sick I'm gonna wear the
whole what do you call it uniform I'm
gonna wear the apron I'm gonna put the
apron on I'm gonna go up there for an
hour and act like I'm working there and
everyone's coming up to me I'm like if
you can play the video to for people to
see Eric if you guys can show this here
press play
yeah that's me right there at Liberty
City okay talking to customers that's
Heaven my cashier I just don't look like
I belong at this place
you you can you're the six four bagger
over here but you know what's funny
everybody's coming up here looking and
they're like what the hell is wrong with
this guy being a banker right I'm
talking to everybody Hey Yolanda how are
you
tell me your story you know how old's
your son five months old where are the
diapers how come you're not buying any
diapers oh I can't afford any diapers we
got to get you some diapers the mom
looks at me like the grandma like her
mom not the kids mom yeah Grandma of the
kid you we do need diapers but we ain't
got the money for right now I said how
many months five months what aisle I go
to aisle number five and I pick up all
the every single diaper box they had for
five month old baby I pick it up I bring
it she's like no no we don't want to buy
it I said how about I pay for it but you
work here I said let me just pay for it
so you know I'm doing my part and I'm
talking to everybody why I want to know
what people are like in Winn-Dixie and
you're going to find out about not
Winn-Dixie in Liberty City by the way
while we're there
uh Sam got the video of this Sam if you
can send those clips to Michael to add
the video as well there's a shooting
right across the street two people get
shot they're moving by I mean this is a
he's right about what the city is like
it's not a safest place it's not a good
anyways we're talking to all these
people and then long story short next
person comes actually who are you I'm
just a regular person no you're not why
are you paying for everyone's groceries
I spent probably four or five thousand
dollars buying everyone's groceries
eventually after 30 minutes everybody
was going through aisle number seven
that's so funny we gotta cleanup 45
minutes I'm like I'm only going to be
here for an hour and 15 minutes yeah but
it was it was learned as such so tell me
about the city what is this place like
where are you from what's the Liberty
City how much has changed the cop that
was there with us she was working at
Winn-Dixie 20 years ago and everybody
was talking to her she's like you
realize that at this Winn-Dixie 20 years
ago there was a shooting every day you
realize where you are I said really yeah
anyways and one lady says why are you
doing this I said look man I came from a
family you know my dad was a cashier at
a 99 Cent Store uh and
I said my dad is standing right there my
dad was standing right next to me just
like 20 feet away watching the whole
thing yeah it's a very unique experience
for this whole thing this is my biggest
challenge for people watching this okay
and what the point I was trying to make
with David Rubinstein and then we can go
into the topics
if you're doing very very very well in
life
if 2022 was a magical year for you
financially you have more money than
you've ever had you're driving nicer
cars than you've ever driven you're
going to the best restaurants regular
you're getting more respect than you
ever have gotten before
go to the complete opposite communities
to get some perspective to realize how
things are in different places and give
back by choice I don't like force that's
taxes I like Choice do it by choice and
learn and take your family let them also
kind of see what that looks like because
that's a paradigm shift that those need
who are doing very well but flip it if
2022 was a shittier for you you went
through a divorce it wasn't fun it was
an exciting bad breakup you know I'm
talking to one of the guys yesterday
he's going through it right now he's in
the middle of a divorce he thought it
was going to be easy it's not it's ugly
you know everything's getting involved
they didn't have anything in place it's
not a nest it's not a nice situation
that he's going through such a rough
year form if you're in a place where
things are not going right you lost 400
000 on bitcoin you were expecting to be
a millionaire now you're barely a
thousandere and things are not going
right to the complete opposite side to
get a paradigm shift go to a Ferrari
dealership and ask the guy to sit on a
Ferrari and just to kind of see how the
salesperson treats you go to a realtor
and go to an open house or five million
dollar home Dream Home in a community
you like to live in go give yourself a
paradigm shift but whatever you do going
into 2023 the one thing that's for sure
nothing's going to change dramatically
unless if you put all the pressure in
building character and create
environments for you to have a paradigm
shift whether it's for you your kids
your family the people you lead start
2023 with that right before this the
only reason why we started a podcast at
9 23 is because today we're was a
Christmas uh what do you call it when
the school does a Christmas uh you know
like a event where the kids were doing
what they were doing I was there today
with all my kids and uh singing it was a
Gilligan's Island play which was awesome
what time was this this was at 8 30 I
was I just got here right right after
that
Hannah we're off to going to spending
time with the family for Christmas but
um you know I I I always you know think
about like you know talking to
Rubenstein I wonder if they're only
talking to billionaires if they're only
talking to people that are in their
situations if they're only talking to
rich people and not realizing the other
side does not trust mainstream media the
other side does not trust the government
you kind of have to be able to hear both
sides out we were just watching a video
by Joe manchin and Joe manchin's being
asked by uh Jake tappers are you leaving
the party he says listen man I'm gonna
vote the same the same way I've always
voted this is who I am whether I change
parties or not that's on me because I
think Kristen's Cinema so everybody's
asking if he's gonna be doing it look
create 2020 create some Paradigm Shift
moments for yourself to make 2023 the
beginning of the greatest years of your
life and it starts with being
intentional not letting you be
accidental so what all the craziness
taking place I believe future looks
right if you believe future looks bright
get your latest Future looks bright hat
of valuetainment it says future looks
bright here future looks bright here we
got them in white we got them in Black
we got them in red our black on black
sold out these are about to sell out if
you haven't ordered one yet we had a
person in Michigan but one then he
bought three then when those three
people weren't in the office they had to
order 58 of them because people wanted
the future looks bright hat especially
during times like this because ain't
nobody's saying future looks bright
toward your future looks bright hat
click over here and to watch the entire
podcast click here take care everybody
good
[Music]